في المقابل كشفت صحيفه فاين شيل تايمز عن
تعاون الولايات المتحده مع تايوان والدول
الحليفه المجاوره تحسبا لاي تحركات عسكريه
صينيه الصحيفه قالت ان الولايات المتحده
ستسلم تايوان اربع طائرات مسيره من طراز
ام كيو بابتداء من عام 2025 وسيتم نشر
المسيرات في تايوان لاستطلاع الاوضاع في
المناطق المحيطه بالجزيره من اليابان
شمالا والى الفلبين جنوبا مسؤول عسكري
مشارك في التخطيط قال لفيننشل تايمز انه
سيتم تدريب القوات التايوانيه على استخدام
هذه المسيرات الى جانب نظرائهم الامريكيين
واليابانيين وفق الصحيفه من المقرر ان يتم
تشارك البيانات بين الولايات المتحده
وتايوان واليابان بشكل فوري ومباشر لتعزيز
التنسيق في حاله وقوع هجوم صيني على
تايوان بعد الحصول على صوره كامله لتحركات
بحريه
للجيش الصيني ومراقبه السفن الحربيه
والغواصات الصينيه طبعا حول هذه الجزيره
وبينما امتنعت وزاره الدفاع ان كان
الامريكيه او حتى اليابانيه ومكتب رئاسه
تايوانيه عن التعليق توقع مسؤول عسكري ان
تعتبر الصين الخطوه الامريكيه بمثابه تصعد
كبير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات